[Musique]
je vais peut-être rebondir par rapport à
ça c'est quand même très particulier des
dans une période où on s'étonne que
quelqu'un vienne sa parole c'est le
contraire que l'on devrait critiquer
c'est comme très souvent on me dit intel
du courage de dire ça je disais qu'elle
ait le courage de dire ce que l'on pense
c'est l'absence de courage que l'on doit
condamner et si j'ai dit cela ça parce
que nous sommes dans un moment de
profond désarroi de profondes
perturbations parce que l'on ne sait
plus quelles sont les vents qui porte où
va le monde
et je voudrais pas être démarrée par
cette phrase qui m'avait beaucoup frappé
de victor hugo qui disait le peuple à
ses colères le volcan à sa lave
elle détruit tout et elle féconde
ensuite et il faut jamais sous-estimer
l'impact d'une technologie pour changer
le monde la géopolitique les américains
en 45 lorsqu'ils avaient atteint 1
s'interroger sur l'écoulement de leur
surproduction ont pu imaginer un
commerce mondial la paix et le commerce
montesquieu par deux technologies le
téléphone qui accélérait la circulation
d'informations et les containers qui
faisait baisser le prix du transport
et derrière un peu comme christophe
colomb en maïs en amérique du sud
honnête avec la religion catholique
ils sont arrivés aussi avec la
démocratie est aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans la troisième révolution
technologique avec le numérique et c'est
quelque chose qui perturbe complètement
tous les repères qui sont les nôtres
pourquoi parce que nous ne sommes plus
dans transformation du monde qui est une
évolution telle qu'on l'a connue de
l'économie rurale économie industrielle
nous rentrons dans une métamorphose est
très souvent se réfugie dans la notion
de crise
or quand vous sortez de la crise vous
retrouvez la situation ex ante et là
vous êtes au contraire dans une
perpétuelle transformation et
métamorphoses du monde ce qui fait que
demain sera totalement différent
d'aujourd'hui et vous avez un premier
choc culturel notamment pour nous un peu
judéo-chrétien nous pensons que
le futur et la projection du présent
dans la baie d'amorphe aux le futur et
la contestation du présent et que
l'avenir appartiendra non pas aux plus
puissants qui vivent dans l'insouciance
lié à l'abri artificielle est illusoire
de leur puissance il ne sera pas au plus
anciens je suis là depuis 150 ans je ne
peux pas être remise en cause si
l'avenir habarcq va appartenir à celles
et ceux qui s'adaptent en permanence
or l'adaptation c'est la prime à la
contestation
celui qui invente celui qui imagine
celui qui conteste ce qui existe et tout
notre système géopolitique a été basée
en fin de compte sur la conformité sur
l'obéissance et sur le refus de la
contestation et nous sommes probablement
en train de nous interroger si la
violence que l'on voit dans le monde
entier
il n'y a pas un pays au monde dans
lequel le système en place n'est pas
contestée par des forces éruptive
spontanée instantanée mobilisatrice
liées plus d'ailleurs par la gestion des
peurs que la gestion des espérances j'y
reviendrai et cela nous interrogeait
probablement que nous avons eu des
discussions des réflexions opérationnel
une des études qui m'interpelle le plus
c'est de dire que probablement la
violence que nous constatons dans le
monde entier et la différence qu'il ya
entre la brutale accélération offertes
par les technologies et la différence
d'adaptation des structures géopolitique
et politico administratif et cette
différence va créer des tensions
extrêmement redoutable les consommateurs
sont partis dans libé risation quand le
système résiste et l'on voit bien que le
système politique cherche à contrôler or
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un moment
où la question fondamentale c'est que
tous nos outils socialisant
qui étaient les idéologies politiques
sont contestés par la réalité les
ultralibéraux pensait que
l'autorégulation du marché allait tout
régler
aujourd'hui développant les inégalités
bernie sanders détacher puis les
calaisiens penser que la relance de
l'argent public allait tout régler
il n'y a jamais eu autant de capitaux
injectés ex nihilo par les banques
centrales
pas de croissance économique pas de
croissance des prix flash ou
artificielle des actifs bull annoncé les
idéologies ou les croyances religieuses
sont remises en cause par l'avancée des
sciences est ce que le robot va remettre
en cause le travail et la socialisation
du travail nous étions dans des rythmes
collectif avec des productions
collectives des protections collectives
et un temps où parier du temps tout à
l'heure l'homme n'a jamais été l'esclave
du temps c'est lui qui s'est muée cela
parce qu'il a inventé la montre il
inventait l'horloge et le rythme de nos
vies était lié par cette vie collective
la mobilité de travail etc
et puis l'on va bien que la famille
elle-même est aujourd'hui questionné
entre un combat qui lie entre la
légitimité des liens du sang et la
réalité des liens affectifs et donc à
partir du moment où tous ceux qui depuis
le départ de l'humanité à socialiser des
hommes est fragilisé qu'est ce qui va
permettre de faire vivre ensemble des
individus de plus en plus singulier et
l'on voit bien que les philosophes ne
répond là dessus c'est peut-être une
transcendance et le général de gaulle
nous avait déjà interpellé là dessus en
disant lorsque les peuples défendent des
causes il s'élève il se transcende
lorsqu'ils défendent des intérêts ils se
déchirent et sans nous entrerons du coup
on y reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure
c'est que dans ce basculement de la
société de consommation dans la volonté
qu'avait les politiques de voir
disparaître leur idéologie qui
permettait de collectiviser leur
adhésion populaire
ils ont souhaité remplacer cette
aspiration idéologique par la quête d'un
pouvoir par la séduction d'un électeur
même si on perd tu es un citoyen
et à partir du moment où on a fait
perdre l'âme de la citoyenneté pour
essayer de séduire les électeurs
on a mis en cause ce qui faisait la
force d'une nation qui s'était après la
guerre soudés par la souffrance et la
peau du sang pour défendre des causes et
qui aujourd'hui se déchirent sur les
souffrances du quotidien or le poète
nous avait alerté victor hugo disait les
nations ne meurt pas mais elles peuvent
se suicider et aujourd'hui quand on est
plus lévi-strauss nous avait aussi
interpellé sur le fait que nos
communautés qu'elles soient entreprises
familiales nation fonctionne sur trois
très grande force les espérances les
peurs et les tentations lorsque les
espérances sont fortes d'un avenir
meilleur
même si vous êtes dans l'insouciance de
ne pas remettre en place ni les dogmes
religieux ni les dogmes politiques
vous n'avez pas peur mais lorsque
ceux-ci brutalement disparaissent la
gestion des peurs émergent et vous voyez
que l'ensemble des partis démocratiques
dans le monde entier cherchent à retenir
des espérances qui fuit ne voyant pas
que les populistes et des extrémistes
gère des peurs qui augmentent et qui
fait que l'on pousse même les gens à la
tentation de quitter la communauté et
faisons en sorte que ne croyant plus à
la loi qui est la force du droit et la
morale collective en revendique le droit
à la force
et l'on assiste à une radicalisation
dans les rapports sociaux dans les
contestations et dans le fait qu'un
certain nombre de jeunes aujourd'hui en
france lille ni patron du battery et
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
révélateur d'une formidable
interpellation de simone veil en 1942 en
dix ans le défi du 21e siècle c'est de
les défis de l'intériorité et le défi de
l'altérité et je voudrais attirer votre
attention là dessus parce que le
numérique pose un problème géopolitique
majeur il fait disparaître les
frontières plus personne ne circule
maîtrise la circulation des capitaux
un trader fait vingt-sept mille
opérations par seconde
plus personne ne maîtrise la circulation
des idées des hommes et des marchandises
s'ils n'auront pas cette réflexion nous
allons devant une formidable guerre des
territoires liés à la chaîne des valeurs
mais pas uniquement dans la localisation
géographique de la tvas là vous êtes
vous même quand vous avez des avis sur
un hôtel sur un restaurant sur le site
trip advisor vous êtes fous un
fournisseur gratuit et créateur d'une
valeur sur un site qui ne vous
appartient pas donc l'on revient que
cette notion de chaîne des valeurs va
créer deux formidables guerre des
territoires avec d'ailleurs un sujet qui
a été posée à obama à l'époque par un
rapport de la cia qui va réguler le
monde demain est ce que ce sont les
états nations
les multinationales ou les mégalopoles
il voit bien que cette capacité que nous
aurons de répondre à celui qui va
réguler le monde va faire peut-être
émerger et ce qui est totalement
invisible sous terrain gras et des lacs
rd pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est pas la
conquête des territoires
c'est la conquête des esprits la
maîtrise des banques de données et on
voit bien que dans cette guerre
l'europe est absente sur le continent
numérique 80% américain 20% de chez noir
personne ne parle du supercalculateur
chinois qui est aujourd'hui cinq fois
plus puissant que le plus puissant
supercalculateur américain et qui fait
que nous sommes dans un moment où ce qui
est important c'est pas le lieu du
pouvoir c'est pas l'illusion de qui
détient le pouvoir c'est celui qui
influencent le pouvoir et le pouvoir
politique est aussi votre pouvoir à vous
les chercheurs américains disent que
vous n'avez plus de vie privée et que ce
qui est important c'est de profiter de
votre temps libéré
si je peux mettre une voiture sans
chauffeur je peux prendre trois heures
de votre temps pour essayer de
l'influencer dans votre lecture dans
votre pensée et donc on voit bien que si
nous ne prenons pas garde nous sommes
dans un moment où l'illusion la plus
redoutable du monde c'est de vous offrir
par les technologies l'impression d'une
liberté jamais jamais connu est en
réalité vous êtes peut-être à la porte
d'un esclavage moderne car vous serez
prisonniers dévotion fabriqués par les
autres et dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et de façon très schématique je m'en
excuse on voit bien que l'économie
rurale c'est d'économie du sol de
l'exploitation du sol de la fertilité
avec l'acceptation d'un quotidien
difficile parce qu'il y avait la
promesse de l'aude la suite un type bien
des rapports puis le basculement dans
les sociétés industrielles exploitation
des sous sols mais soutenu société de
consommation ça n'est plus la
satisfaction des besoins qui engendre
une insatisfaction
c'est la satisfaction des envies qui
engendre une frustration et une douleur
sociale car l'homme vaut plus pour ce
qu'ils dépensent que ce qu'il pense et
l'on a fait perdre le chemin de la
construction de conviction certes imposé
par le haut autant rural et religieux
mais ce qui est intéressant dans ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que nous
basculons de cette société du sol et du
sous-sol à la société de l'intelligence
la société des cerveaux ou d'évoquer
tout à l'heure et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne sait pas maîtriser et dearlove
de risque on est dans la lettre b et de
la découverte du cerveau et je salue
micha parce que je sais qu'il est dans
cette réflexion sur alzheimer
si l'on part du principe que ce qui est
important c'est pas la richesse des sols
et la richesse des sous-sols temps
d'éviter la conquête des territoires
c'est le capital humain
un chercheur américain a monté depuis
1999 que dans la valeur d'une entreprise
des actifs immatériels été supérieures
aux actifs matériels à ce moment là nous
devons revisité complètement notre
lecture politique car en france on
analyser la force d'un pays à la force
des bras puis à son génie technologique
si vous êtes dans le capital humain
chaque individu doit être regardée non
pas en fonction de ses échecs échouent à
l'école tu es nul
ta femme est parti et nulle d'aller
bosser le bilan est nul n'a pas de rolex
cellule on doit exactement regarder au
niveau de l'intelligence
sur le regard positif et potentiel de
l'individu l'élève qui échouent à
l'école c'est pas un raté c'est une
intelligence qu'on n'a pas su mobiliser
la personne âgée c'est pas quelqu'un d'
inutile
c'est une intelligence mobilisables le
chômeur même chose et droit bien qu'à
partir du moment où nous sommes dans ce
regard l'on voit bien que
l'investissement dans le capital humain
va devoir revisiter la totalité de nos
investissements publics et privés qui
fait que nous allons passer de la
société la performance qui écrase
d'individus à la société de
l'épanouissement qui valorise
potentiellement de l'acquisition au
partage du bien aux liens c'est quelque
chose assez fascinant parce que dans la
bataille des idées que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure si l'on reste obnubilée par
l'acquisition des connaissances et pas
par l'éveil des consciences
nous sommes en train de livrer nos
enfants et nos petits enfants à des
capacités de manipulation intellectuelle
qui fait que dans la communauté des
semblables qui les rassemble il vit
aujourd'hui en communauté dans lequel
s'échangent des rumeurs s'échangent des
contre vérités qui sont plus audibles à
leurs yeux que de vérités scientifiques
nous avons déjà cet exemple en france
plus personne ne veut se vacciner quand
toutes les autorités médicales disent
qu'il faut le faire donc nous sommes
dans un moment où si l'on ne prend pas
autant le temps bataille du temps et les
esprits dès le plus jeune âge de
réfléchir à l'éveil des consciences de
nos enfants dès l'école maternelle à
leur apprendre le débat nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
d'avoir un débat qui soutient le système
le débat est un combat qui veut faire
assez celui qui ne pense pas comme vous
alors qu'aujourd'hui le débat ça peut
être l'enrichissement par la différence
qu'elle changeait de voir un débattre
avec quelqu'un qui ne partage pas mon
point de vue et donc l'investissement
sur le capital humain sur sa liberté
c'est le moyen d'offrir à quelqu'un de
se construire une conviction d'avoir le
temps nécessaire de la démocratie n'ont
pas participative
mais délibérative permettant aux gens de
pouvoir se poser un certain nombre de
questions faut-il sortir de l'euro ou
pas est-ce que l'immigré est un facteur
d'aggravation du danger terroriste ou au
contraire un enrichissement économique
si nous n'avons pas la capacité de
sortir de ce carcan de l'instantané nous
voyons bien que nous allons vivre en
permanence sur de gestion émotionnelle
des peurs plutôt que de construire des
convictions qui vont stabiliser un monde
de plus en plus instable et nous voyons
bien que les neurologues pose aussi la
question de l'ine d'acquis la façon dont
on a envi ron quelqu'un dans sa
dimension affective dans cette version
professionnelle dans sa dimension de
mobilité jouent considérablement sur sa
capacité de comportement puisque l'on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il ya des
modifications de cerveau par rapport à
l'environnement
selon que vous êtes pauvres précaire
agressé vous n'avez pas les mêmes
fonctionnement cérébraux ils voient bien
que dès le plus jeune âge on peut avoir
quelqu'un qu'il sera en échec permanent
et donc en conflit permanent et en
violence permanente et l'objectif votre
attention que c'est une formidable
opportunité
nous sommes en train de vivre un monde
qui impose la fragilité du mans et la
fragilité de la nature qu'on évoquera
tout à l'heure alors quand cette notion
de fragilité arrive c'est une magnifique
opportunité car on a envie de se battre
que ce que pour l'homme que ce pour quoi
on a peur de perdre quelque chose et ce
que l'on a peur de perdre
c'est la notion de fragilité un amour un
emploi un enfant une situation est donc
il ya un moment politique extraordinaire
qui fait qu'en prenant cette sensibilité
de la fragilité de soi même mais aussi
de l'autre si nous on n'a pas le sens de
l'autre
si l'autre est un rejet parce que nous
sommes dans des réflexes suicidaire plus
faut penser monde plon porsche court
terme plan pour ce village
plus vous passer moyen terme plus on
pense court terme plus il faut penser
l'autre plus on pense chacun pour soi
ils voient bien que vous devez tous être
aujourd'hui acteur de votre propre
destin et responsable quand on donne aux
peuples eux le moyen d'être intelligent
il est intelligent
et donc aujourd'hui nous pouvons plus
être spectateur de la scène publique
devront être acteur car directement
concernés l'avenir vous appartient
il est entre vos mains non pas par la
maîtrise technologique mais parce que la
technologie nous permet aujourd'hui de
pouvoir éveiller les consciences
construire des convictions et accepter
l'autre même s'ils ne partagent pas vos
convictions et l'acceptation de l'autre
comme facteur d'enrichissement est le
temps qu un facteur de ralentissement
pour mieux réfléchir sur soi même est
une formidable bataille du 21e siècle
our en réalité quand on donne du temps à
sa vie quand on donne de la vie à son
temps c'est plus important que d'avoir
du temps à sa vie
merci de votre attention